At the heart of our plan is a tax cut for
everyday working Americans.
Donald Trump has declared "with tax reform,
we can make it morning in America again"
and that "revising our tax code is not just
a policy discussion —
it's a moral one, because we are not talking
about the government's money –
we are talking about your money, your hard
work."
So we overhaul and streamline the Internal
Revenue Service.
The Republican tax plan, which would cut rates
for individuals and small businesses,
sounds like good policy, but it’s not.
The hallmark of a good tax code is that it
doesn’t attempt social engineering
via revenue collection..
It's our money and the government shouldn't
be telling us how to spend it
or what to spend it on.
And yet our tax code is larded up with all
sorts of incentives
for certain types of purchases—such as the
mortgage-interest deduction,
which is defended on the grounds that owning
a home is
morally and culturally superior to renting.
It’s not by the way, and the result is market
distortions
that saddle families that would be better
off renting with mortgage debt.
Trump's tax plan keeps the mortgage interest
deduction--
and the one for charitable giving, which is
another example of social engineering.
Another distortion in the tax code
is that individuals can deduct the cost of
their state and local taxes
from their federal bill,
effectively allowing jurisdictions like New
York and California
to get away with charging their residents
more than they would otherwise.
To its credit, the Trump plan at least attempts
to do away with this practice,
although it’s doubtful this idea will survive
the legislative process..
The most important principle for tax reform
is that revenue should cover the actual costs
of government
so that citizens can actually make an informed
decisions
about what services they're willing to pay
for.
On this score, Trump's plan is sadly business
as usual.
You have not answered, though, a simple question
did you use that 916 million dollar loss to
avoid paying personal federal income taxes?
Of course I do, of course I do, and so do
all of her donors or most of her donors.
First, it would take even more people off
the tax rolls.
There are already over 40 million households
that pay no federal income tax at all
and the president brags that his plan would
add another 31 million to that total.
How could it be that nearly half the country
pays no taxes?
According to the Tax Policy Center 46.4% of
households pay no federal income tax.
Who are these non-payers?
As Chris Edwards of the Cato Institute writes,
"taking more people off the tax rolls is not
a good way to keep the government limited.
If something is 'free,' people will demand
more of it."
And the problem is much bigger than that.
For decades now, the feds have been spending
far more in any year
than they take in via taxes.
Last year, for instance, the government spent
20 percent more than it took in
and between 2009 and 2013, it spent 33 percent
more than it brought in.
Hence annual deficits and ballooning national
debt.
This is like government by Groupon: Every
year, we're getting such a great deal,
of course we want more and more stuff.
We'd be stupid not to.
That is why the foundation of our job creation
agenda
is to fundamentally reform our tax code
for the first time in more than 30 years.
Now where does Trump's plan land on this topic?
Who knows?
Every tax reform promises to be either be
revenue neutral
or to increase the government's haul.
Would you be willing to raise your right hand
and look at the American people and say
'I Steven Mnuchin promise you that this will
be revenue neutral and deficit neutral.'
Well it will have to be revenue neutral, we
have a 21 trillion dollar debt.
He says it's revenue neutral, that's Washington
speak for 'I don't know.'
In many cases, neither outcome is close to
being truthful.
More to the point, after years of accumulating
debt
we need to focus on government spending first
and foremost.
In 2016, the feds took in about $3 trillion
in taxes.
That should be the absolute spending limit—
instead of the nearly $4 trillion Congress is talking about.
Taxes aren't the price we pay for civilization—
they're the price we pay for government.
And until we bind government and taxes together,
we'll be spending more and more money that
we don't have
on things we almost certainly wouldn't want
if we had to pay full price for them.